ever tried running backwards what about
running a mile backwards in 5 and 1/2
minutes this man has that 5 minutes and
30 second backwards mile go a lot of
times people think maybe I ran the film
in Reverse I'm like no I'm actually like
literally running backwards meet Aaron
Yoder one of the world's fastest
backwards Runners with that mile being
about twice as fast as the average
forwards Runner and that's just one in a
long list of backwards running accolades
I had held three Guinness World Records
seven World titles 10 American titles
and certainly more records to
come backwards running is certainly a
niche sport just because it's so weird
to think about is it actually a thing I
mean when I was in Germany doing my
first world championships there's about
a hundred athletes and probably 100
Spectators out there watching but even
if the sport is obscure Aaron loves
going out to run and always strives to
grow as an athlete we're currently at
cornado Heights right outside of
lindborg Kansas and this is a great
place that I use for doing my long runs
I would say on a given day I run two to
three miles backwards I try not to look
behind because just like forward running
if you are turning around and looking
behind you then that slows you down I
simply make sure that the road is clear
then I just go after it I really have to
trust myself and kind of run by faith
Faith you have to have a lot of belief
that you're good God's got
you as far as the mechanics of backwards
running I'm lifting my feet up another
thing that I use as a queue is kicking a
soccer ball so I'll bring that leg out
in front and then I'm lifting my foot up
and I'm placing it back on the ground
making sure my foot is directly
underneath my hips and I'm trying to
make sure as I make ground contact that
my toe is up so I get a nice springboard
there's a temptation to doing kind of a
back pedal where you're bent over and
you're kind of reaching back but when
you're staying nice and Tall your
balance is going to be enhanced very
similar to forward running you don't
want to be reaching back behind but
simply lifting and pushing maintaining
good posture don't want my head up in
the sky or be looking straight down I'm
basically just gazing about 20 m in
front so I keep good neutral spine
position trying to keep my upper body
nice and loose driving my elbow
backwards keeping my hands to the side
and really just staying nice and tall
when I'm training for a distance run I'm
not lifting my feet up as much so I'm
not activating the hip flexor and the
quadricep quite as much as I would if I
was running at the track we're here at
Bethany college track this is where I
coach this is where I train this is
where all the magic happens some of the
big things that change with backwards
running is the start forward sprinters
would start in a four-point stance their
lead leg and their strong leg is out in
front and then they would be up in this
position with backwards running you
can't really use blocks so I start in a
two-point position and whichever is your
stronger leg for me it's my right is in
the back I make sure I'm up on the for
foot the heels are up and then when I
start I try to swing my torso backwards
but that's what's in my mind when I'm
trying to go as fast as humanly possible
with that in mind we decided to see just
how fast aing can
run
I felt
[Music]
that does it look fast it looks fast I
need coaching you know it look
fast I'm chasing the dragon now I'm
starting to run tense cuz I'm like
trying too
hard pushing himself to the Limit Aaron
hit 12 mph at of Sprint which is a 5
minute mile Pace but as fast as Aaron
now is his retro running Pursuits begin
with a setback when I was halfway
through college I banged hang my knee up
had to torn my Meniscus so I went in for
surgery started having some real issues
like just a lot of pain you know slowing
down in my training so I went back to
the doctor and said you you got pretty
bad arthritis like I would recommend you
never run again remember that day I was
at cornado Heights just really trying to
figure out how I can just get away from
everything and I remember on that
particular day it's almost as if God was
saying just turn it
around and so I went and ran four miles
backwards with no pain the new dream
became I'm going to train for for 6
weeks and see where it takes me I
remember thinking it's like this is just
a good type of exercise for me and I
started looking it's like there's World
Championships there's world records I'm
like am I actually going to step up and
make an attempt then on the first
attempt I broke the
record now maybe not a lot of people
understand like why would you want to
put yourself through that pain somebody
who's going through a challenge in life
a student or an athlete they could maybe
look at my perspective I know I'm at my
best when I've put myself through some
sort of challenge each day I think
people should try running backwards
because it's just a different overall
perspective in American culture we're
goal oriented and we're forward driven
so it allows you to think about how far
I've come rather than how far I need to
continue to
go this is my office as a coach here and
teacher at Bethany have a lot of things
that really proud of in terms of what
we've done done as a team they have
pictures of some teams that had
qualified for Nationals I definitely
love backwards running love being a
world record holder but to me what's
more important is being able to teach
and coach this time in their life is
very important and I'm grateful to have
the opportunity to hopefully Inspire but
certainly I get a lot of inspiration
from working with everyone that I do and
with his enthusiasm for coaching Aaron
volunteered to teach me to run backwards
as fast as he can we ready to run
backwards Wendy that'll be my my first
time okay Wendy you're on let's see what
you got just from scratch can I look
behind me or you can maybe I would try
to stay you know looking this
way all right you got some really good
things that you're doing with posture
but you started with the same leg and
same arm out in front you know we're not
Mario characters running around like
this we run with a cross connection your
right leg's out in front so then your
left hand needs to be here so then when
you start going your arms are switching
and then just start going backwards a
little bit there we go hey yeah you you
can do it you can do it so let's try it
again go there we go there we go there
we go that's pretty good that's pretty
good that's pretty good there we go good
good I'm bending this knee in the front
because I'm still going to push off a
little bit here you don't want to be
already straight that way you get a
little bit of push off both legs
go look at that look at that just keep
on doing it just keep on doing it I got
it I got it I got it
ah yeah I could do this see I look
behind me yeah that's all right there's
a
sandbag it's like there's a well I think
I'm a professional now let's race let's
go on your mark get set
go well it's close so close that's close
that so close that might need to we need
finish here that might be hundreds of a
second I was right behind you so you
beat me by a little bit couple feet
maybe game of inches game of yards
that's right what if I run forward
against you backwards I like that yeah
on your mark good set
go I'm really
trying that one was actually a photo but
if I actually lean backwards I don't
know if I want to do that there's no
catching yourself all right you're a
clearly very fast backwards Runner
because you are kind of at speed with my
fastest forward running I think you did
a great job and definitely presented a
good challenge maybe next time I'll be
able to get you with the forward running
thank you so much coach as much as he
wins winning is never the end goal for
Aaron who has dedicated himself to
backwards running as a true
self-fulfilling passion I love running
backwards someone had mentioned at one
point well you're just such a natural
athlete you wouldn't even be good at
backwards running if it wasn't for that
the thing is I'm not a natural backwards
Runner because it's not natural we're
not designed to do that but it does feel
natural to me I certainly see backwards
running growing you know if it becomes
an Olympic sport then maybe the NCAA
picks up something like that and then
you have schools that could give people
opportunities that maybe they're not a
good forward Runner but they're a great
backwards Runner so who would be the
coach for that it would be
[Music]
me